more than a decade ago geuman barked on  a small car program sitting here today I  cannot tell you why it took so long for  a safety defect to be announced for this  program but I can tell you we will find  out this is an extraordinary situation  it involves vehicles we no longer make  but it came to light on my watch so I'm  responsible for resolving it when we  have answers we will be fully  transparent with you with our regulators  and with our customers while I cannot  turn back the clock as soon as I learned  about the problem we acted without  hesitation we told the world we had a  problem that needed to be fixed we did  so because whatever mistakes were made  in the past we will not shirk from our  responsibilities now or in the future  today's GM will do the right thing that  begins with my sincere apologies to  everyone who has been affected by this  recall especially the families and  friends who lost their lives or were  injured I am deeply sorry